this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by tushy
upstart manscaped and keeps more on that
later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
night pants studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler
on all social media uh night pants
nation i can't thank you
enough for all of your support for real
you guys are the best
and you know what else feels really good
every time i go out and about somewhere
and somebody
comes on the show uh or they'll hit me
up and i'll say man you got the best
fans and i do
so thank you for real um make sure
you are subscribed to the youtube
channel you're getting video over there
every tuesday
audio on monday uh make sure you're
subscribed to the patreon page guys
um there are two honeydews a week one is
on the patreon page
i'm keeping it as cheap as i can you're
getting video and audio
it's five bucks a month no tears no
nothing 60 a year
you're getting 52 episodes a year extra
all right
and i'm just doing the honeydew with
y'all
uh honeydew the honeydew podcast let me
slow my words down is the website and
that's where the merch is
all that stuff the hoodies the night
shorts
i mean you guys are the [ __ ] best i'm
sitting here thinking of night pants you
guys are like hey won't we cut the legs
off
and i'm like yeah why don't we cut the
[ __ ] light let's cut the night pants
off with the knees y'all
got nice shorts out there hoodies
everything so
thank you thank you thank you um and as
always i record here at santa monica
music center
if you are looking to take some online
music lessons uh this is the spot
you'll be trained by local los angeles
musicians
and if you go to santa monica music dot
com you use the code honeydew
they will waive the registration fee and
give you one free lesson when you sign
up
for a package all right now
you all know we do over here we
highlight the low lights and as i always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers i am very excited to have
uh
this storyteller on today for the first
time here on the honeydew y'all let's
welcome thomas arago
everybody welcome to the honeydew bro i
appreciate you man
thank you did i say it right you did
pretty good for a while just like i said
[Laughter]
um well welcome to the show this is
thank you
to uh marty actually for for connecting
us
marty o'neal the [ __ ] thank you marty um
i like the crossover here
and uh what i didn't know is i didn't
know this was your first
guest on i didn't know that so i was
very flattered and excited because i
know you're stoked to be here
yeah dude thank you yes thank you um so
before we get into
your stories because you have quite a
bit to tell um please promote
everything and anything you want um go
to dopaziola.com
pushtrees.com that's my clothing company
uh dopaziola on youtube
and yoli youtube on instagram if it's
still there i get like i told you
yeah you've been telling me they [ __ ]
deleted it they shut you down yeah
i didn't know that at all yeah it's a
what the [ __ ] yeah that's all it's all
right
well i want to talk to you i think the
easiest way i you know i ask everybody
to send me stuff i'm pointing over to
the the monitor with your stuff on there
and yours
is a hell of a chronological story as as
some peoples are and some aren't so why
don't you
uh start from the beginning for us
please okay
um i'm from merced california you said
you do know
where that's from it's a [ __ ] but i
lie it's where i'm from
it's just full of meth and gangs it runs
on methane like
ebd cars and [ __ ] that's the whole town
um
i don't know i grew up there i don't
speak spanish but i'm brown as [ __ ]
so it was very hard for me to not get
like
every time someone's speaking spanish i
don't [ __ ] know what you're saying
looking down on you oh when i went to
canada like cool holy [ __ ] everywhere i
walked
huh do they walk up to you and speak to
you in spanish
yeah and like absolutely what the [ __ ]
what's that feel like inside to have to
tell them
the worst man customs at customs
the lady looked at me mexican yeah
like that out loud yeah
all right we'll see you out right there
i mean come on man
and then there's a white guy behind like
that dude i'm telling you
i i don't fit the description i know
that [ __ ] but it's okay hats happen a
lot though
yeah and you just feel it inside you
have to how many times would you have to
say you think in your life i don't speak
spanish
no i grew up i grew up in a town of
mexican town
yeah it's a field it's a field worker
town and uh
there's me yeah but uh merced's good i
i guess it's where you that's where you
grow up i'm sure it's home yeah
it's a home i love going back it's
[ __ ] awesome but other than that it's
there's not a lot of opportunity but
that's why i left that's why i live in
la so
but what was it like for you growing up
there because things
were you were exposed to [ __ ] very young
yes
um like i said gangs and drugs so gangs
was the first thing i
no drugs sorry take it back so my best
friend preston
i'm sorry his dad preston big breast
he's a [ __ ] giant dude
i was playing at his house i was about
four and you know when you're a kid like
[ __ ] that water hose there's 12 people
on that [ __ ] i'm going inside to get
some water
i walked in and i just saw this mexican
dude on the table just like this
it's a little ass brown fat me just
walks in and this guy has this big
pile of white i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm looking at and he just does this
and i stop and then i just he press and
he puts his
puts his hand over my face starts
walking me out and my mom's real mean
i forgot to mention that he said my mom
will he's like your mom's gonna [ __ ]
kill me and he just drew me outside by
my face
oh big preston big pressure scared of
your mom
oh yeah no no for sure
not little not my best friend his dad
he's a giant man
and he said your mom's gonna [ __ ]
kill me and threw me out
um i think i was the first place i ever
saw weed and zigzag so
i mean it's not a big deal but the coke
[ __ ] i just knew
that's the [ __ ] on scarface i've seen
scarface before let's get the [ __ ] out
yeah yeah my mom my mom did not i grew
up on movies like uh
the cable guy yeah exactly like that
like hey watch this like
[ __ ] all right now spawn killers there
we go oh [ __ ] i'm just getting [ __ ]
brainwashed but yeah dude
um drugs drugs runs that town but
i mean i ended up you're exposed that
young yeah but it's not like it [ __ ]
me up
i knew drugs were bad i still didn't
smoke weed till i was way older
i was i knew it was bad so i knew i just
get the [ __ ] away from this guy
because my mom will beat my ass that's
all i know my mom will [ __ ] kill me
do anything wrong she's gonna stab me
she's gonna break my legs she said that
[ __ ] to me all the time
she would say it to you i'll break your
legs you always say that [ __ ] i'll break
your [ __ ] legs
which brings me to the next thing the
gangs this is when it first happened you
get
jumped in in the house no my mom my mom
will wake me up with a [ __ ]
belt it's happened many times i was
playing with a match
and she found out she woke me up with a
[ __ ] studded belt on my back
a studded belt she's a fool man she is
a 90s mom she was 18 though so i
understand your mom was 18
when she had me yeah but 16 with my
sister so
they were kids i understand yeah she is
a kid
they were kids in a drug town the [ __ ]
do you expect you're gonna be
trying to keep their kids crying off the
drugs yeah no my mom
oh i resp she's the reason i don't have
10 kids i'm not a gang i'm not in jail
because she
[ __ ] punched me in the face all day
punched me in the face if i did some
crazy [ __ ]
so i knew to stay away what's the
hardest your mom's ever hit you for real
okay that's a good one when she kicked
me the [ __ ] out one time when i was 16
because my life i'm i'm afraid of her
like uh you know like an older brother
like oh
i'm bigger but you [ __ ] me up but my
mom's scary she's
she's loud and she's scary and she
punched me in the [ __ ] face because i
didn't mow the lawn because it didn't
[ __ ] work and i'm telling her it
doesn't work
what do you want me to do and she just
cracked me in the [ __ ] face dude did
nothing
and that's the day i stopped being
afraid of my mom i was 16 years old
that was it i told her too i took her i
[ __ ] [ __ ] out on it i didn't hit my
mom no yeah
you're like that's it it's the last one
oh [ __ ] that's
it it's over you don't care anymore
because i even told her that's [ __ ]
it
and then i grabbed my [ __ ] over here
you'll see [ __ ] my rod ain't
over dude she's crazy she's
back then well oh my god my little
brother now is 16. he got the cool nice
version of her
which is dope you know it's [ __ ]
awesome seeing that [ __ ]
but yeah my mom was uh she was an
[ __ ]
yeah i tell her to her face so you were
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the time man but
like i said we have a relationship
that's like
stop [ __ ] doing that and it won't
there's the outcome what the [ __ ] do you
expect
so it's kind of like a brother-sister
thing but yeah like i said the first
time she told her i'll break your
[ __ ] legs
she used to say that often but she said
it for the first time for real and she
grabbed me by my [ __ ] shirt
is when i was leaving school second
grade
and this [ __ ] kid in a red shirt i
was in the second [ __ ] grade
and this kid comes up to me and goes
what are you bang and i go what the [ __ ]
does that mean
what are you talking about i'm just with
my backpack full power ranger [ __ ] what
are you talking about
you know i'm [ __ ] in second grade and
he goes what do you bang
i said what the what are you talking
about i had a bad mouth i said what the
[ __ ] you talking about
and you go i claim red i go all right i
[ __ ] kept walking
and i got home i told my mom and she
straight [ __ ] put me like grabbed me
by the shirt i'll break your [ __ ]
legs eventually we can grip all over
here
[Applause]
over here i ever hear that blood [ __ ] i
will break your [ __ ] hand
thank you for that that was such a
[ __ ] better way of looking at it man
because it just scared the [ __ ] out of
me
yo she was uh like i said she's a
[ __ ] it's a gang town and she's
trying to keep and my dad my dad was
dumb
when he was young he tried to do gang
stuff but my dad's like me he's very
nice
were your parents together no they broke
up when i was like three
or four because sorry
my dad and my mom used to fight like
crazy and uh
[ __ ] that you said they broke up i mean
it sounds funny she was like
she was 18. that is a beautiful breakup
[ __ ] each other
up they your mom would fight with your
dad really
yeah a lot i've never even talked about
this [ __ ] wow
my bad my dad's good now he's like a
[ __ ] straight edge it's great
but no i see my dad beat the [ __ ] out of
my mom and i see my mom [ __ ] my dad
up my mom knocked my dad out unconscious
many times
come manny bro my mom is [ __ ] she's
[ __ ] like sister she's like a little
rosie perez
but she'll [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
you and that's how i grew up like
be polite hold the [ __ ] door open how
does she knock him out what do you
smash him in the face punch him in the
face and she tried to run
over the they were wild kids you know
but me growing up i just go oh they're
fighting
she's falling x-men [ __ ] play [ __ ]
sega yeah your dad's got a glass jaw
oh [ __ ] it out of here no no my dad beat
the [ __ ] out of her too
jesus yeah uh the last time i remember
when they broke up
they were so they were never married no
they
they broke up my dad was 23. my mom was
21
probably they were [ __ ] kids you know
what i'm saying yeah um
but i walked in and my dad was beating
the [ __ ] out of my mom with his belt
and they were both naked and i was like
what the [ __ ] is happening
i was a little kid that might have been
the one time he wasn't beating the [ __ ]
your mom
[Music]
that might have been the one time your
mom was actually asking for
curricular [ __ ] they were doing no no no
that's not what it
[Music]
[ __ ] was christ man
oh no then he started punching him in
the face right
and then i jumped on her i was like hey
knock it off and my dad started crying
wait you jumped in the middle of your
well
yeah they're naked oh man
you know how awkward i was how awkward
it is i can't imagine something my mama
didn't look at her
i still didn't put the dick away dad and
i was like
and he just started like cheering and
they broke up that day that was it
that was it that was it because he threw
my little sweatshirt my older sister but
when i
stopped and stopped him he threw my
[ __ ] sister across the room all
twacked out
so was it a substance abuse no they
should do meth
my dad used to crank a lot and so but
your mom never called for help huh she
falls she [ __ ] him up that's what i'm
saying that's
the [ __ ] out of me yeah she wasn't like
that's like she helped my dad man
i've seen my mom hook up on a few people
[ __ ] up all them no
well one day you'll i'll just show you a
picture for her later you know oh i
could see it
she's scary man she like [ __ ]
roseanne she's just scary
um but that was the first time that she
told me i'll break your [ __ ] legs to
circle back
was the gangs so you went home and said
something about this i asked her i go
what does that mean to bang and she's
straight just
[ __ ] grab me and tell him i'll break
your [ __ ] legs
and then well when she taught me not to
hit girls too because my dad used to
beat my mom
she told me you want to hear all right
here's the technique
she said i'm four this is right when
they broke her mom's time
when they broke up and fresh we used to
live in fresno for a year
so they broke up after that fight and my
mom was lecturing me on like not today
girls that's why i don't hate girls
because well she [ __ ]
she's scary she told me she'll [ __ ]
kill me i will stab you i will kill you
i'll send you to jail
you hit your girlfriend do you
understand how strong
women especially are she raised me my
whole life but think about like how
strong
women are to [ __ ] have
to be beaten to be beaten and then
still look at your kid and go don't do
that yes don't you know what i'm saying
to literally take a beating and still
have to be the
the parent and go hey what you see
happening to me
[ __ ] up yes do not do this to women
like good
god the burden exactly no wonder she
wanted to whip people's ass
she's scary man what's your mom's name
emily emily emma i got the nicest little
emily ann that's the nicest sweetest
little man
i know i know but uh she's uh
she's the reason why it came out not
shitty for real
it only takes one y'all it only takes
one parent
saves me one goal one good one yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah nobody one good one that's
great
that's great them together is [ __ ]
explosive other than that my dad is the
nicest
never [ __ ] does that again them
together was just all bad
you know they're just not right for each
other they're born five days apart
they're just too much alike oh really
yeah they're just too much like they're
like brother and sister
yeah yeah um so that's that's really uh
how i started seeing my mom just
teach me [ __ ] but the way like i said
the way she told me not to hit girls
she said girls are [ __ ] stupid
they'll hit themselves to make it look
like you hit them you go to jail
and i'm sitting there no they wouldn't
no they would and my mom
yes f i remember looking up at her
[ __ ] x-men on sega
to the right of me there's windows
behind us we're in [ __ ] clovis she's
telling me this and she's crying as she
does it and i'm sitting there like what
the [ __ ] is happening
what the [ __ ] did you do what did i do
you know but
now i get it that she's she's [ __ ]
tripping she's
having to explain this to me right and
she tells me what you do
is they'll hit themselves right she says
you sit on their chest
you push your head your hand on their
head so they don't slam it into the
ground
you put your knees on their shoulders
you call the cops and that's it
so don't hit them because they're you're
gonna go to jail but they will hurt
themselves
and i'm sitting there like [ __ ] no
girl would just hurt themselves to make
somebody get in trouble
you know what i'm trying to process the
[ __ ] i'm trying to process this [ __ ]
trying to process like
my dad is not here you know but
the next day i'm just playing like
catching my dad so i didn't
think of it all they're fighting me my
sister fight too you know what i'm
saying
so it didn't really bug me didn't it was
nor unfortunately it was normal
yeah it did yeah and i didn't see it all
the time right you know and it wasn't
like they were beating each other all
the time
but we weren't around they were [ __ ]
each other up so
that's how i learned the don't hit girls
don't join gangs
[ __ ] from my mom yeah but because you
could have gone the other way
i mean dude people my whole life right
now you could be naked in some bedroom
beating somebody
right now i could be doing this with a
kid running it
your son running in i'm telling you i'll
never forget that [ __ ] that was that is
yeah that is a lot of layers also
if they were fully clothed normally
that's a [ __ ] up situation
so when i jumped on i couldn't [ __ ]
get anywhere
i swear to god it was a watershed damn
stop
i was sick i'm getting sick
i'm getting sequential
oh that is terrible
that's just funny thank god you see it
that way
no matter what i mean if i told you i
saw this guy beating this thing they
were
[ __ ] naked like what happened that's
what this little kid came in
bounce around on the water bed and save
the day funny man
it's funny um all right so
there's a so you're obviously introduced
to drugs and
violence domestic violence yeah but very
early
yeah they broke up after that but then
my mom's not nice when i was a kid she
was very mean
so it was just now my mom but my dad was
the fun one but he's not there so yeah
it went and then we moved to la for a
year and a half my mom met
my mom met some guy i saw a guy walk in
the room they introduced and they stared
at each other
it's like a movie like goodfellas
started and then there he was
and then it just starts that's what
happened they stared at each other
and my mom moved to l.a we lived in
merced they looked at each other once
said you remember that i remember
looking at why is my mom looking
like this is a brand new person because
i didn't know who he was i'm looking at
this tim curry looking [ __ ] dude
and i look at my mom and then we moved
to la with the guy
[ __ ] with him whoa we moved into him
so where did you meet him
in merced that's where they met his
first mom's friend's
uh boyfriend's friend that's it but i
remember they walked in the door saw
like get the [ __ ] out are you guys
serious
but i'm a kid i'm just looking at it
like why are my mom my mom doesn't look
at anybody like that
and then we moved to l.a and then that's
when like
that's when [ __ ] got rough man it was
my mom's i mean it it's been so easy so
far
no no it got rough for physic like it
got rough to the
all right look at my [ __ ]
smoking meth i didn't know that at the
time
right so like food wasn't like hey did
the kids [ __ ] eat today
but as a kid i just know you're hungry
and [ __ ] you know what i mean at school
i get to eat [ __ ] hamburgers at lunch
i come home i just wait to go to [ __ ]
school but not
all the time they're [ __ ] weird he
was a weird [ __ ] man
i didn't like the guy robert he's he's a
dick um
i one time peed on the [ __ ] floor in
my room and blamed it on his cat
so he'd have to clean it up and i pissed
up the wall a little
and my mom straight believed that it was
his cat and said my son wouldn't [ __ ]
do that
and then i'm watching this man clean my
piss and then that's how i got back at
him
he was a piece of [ __ ] i [ __ ] hated
the guy it smells a lot like gatorade
i'm not gonna lie no he said my cat's a
[ __ ] girl dogs
why would i piss on the wall but like in
the corner
you're what i'm saying i was [ __ ]
sick i thought it'd be [ __ ] i thought
it'd be funny
you know i thought it'd be funny it is
funny especially watching him [ __ ] do
it
looking at me but my mom will beat
the [ __ ] out of him if he's trying
that's right yeah he tries to fake me or
anything my mom's going to [ __ ] you up
so he knew better and the cat it was
great yeah
that was great but though he put a
[ __ ] chain on the refrigerator so we
couldn't
open it unless they were that like
unless he opened it it was weird man
it was very like looking back i see
pictures like a stick figure kid
but i didn't know that's why i'm fat as
[ __ ] i think cause i got home my
grandma's like what do you want like
[ __ ] sunny delight
mcdonald's the [ __ ] you think i won you
know they didn't even watch sandlot all
day and eat this [ __ ]
um so when my mom broke up with him we
came back to merced
my mom was straight she was good she was
working to stop doing drugs completely
that's good yeah but she was still
[ __ ] mean like the punching that
she's emily ann she's nice now she's
very nice now but when we were kids she
was not
but uh that's merced and how i started
growing up
and remember i told you she hates gangs
all that [ __ ]
so then she meets her husband or soon to
be husband
and i try to tell you like i'm i'm
[ __ ] brown
you can see that i'm brown i'm a brown
kid my mom looks like a white lady
because my whole other side's jewish and
then my other side is mexican
okay so white well i'm saying jewish but
they're like polish and something
they're all
i'm not doing the seven days of haunting
i tried to do with my grandma she's
sitting
another [ __ ] language and i made fun
of it once and then she got so mad she
never did it again
and we had a regular christmas for the
rest of my life man so my mom looks like
a white lady
for somewhat so she marries this guy
i'm just going to call him my stepdad
because i don't want to
yo you'll see why sure he's a [ __ ]
prison bird you could see it
right i'm playing hacky sack i'm like
eight playing hacky sack in the [ __ ]
yard just trying to do tricks
and this guy walks in with my mom
[ __ ] axel rose walks in basically he
had long hair like
[ __ ] hair white dude blue eyes and i
looked at him
like why the [ __ ] are you standing with
him like that like oh [ __ ] it's her
boyfriend
you know what i mean like this is this
is it this is introductions my mom had
hello
different boyfriend greg oh [ __ ]
no dude he was he had overalls on
overalls in the shirt under you remember
huh you really do have a good memory
traffic man
and uh he's doing hacky sack over his
head showing me i love i fell in love
with the guy instantly
oh this is your boyfriend [ __ ] yeah he
just showed me how to do all the tricks
watch this
she dates him for two three months and
then he goes to jail right but i just
know him do you know how they met
my mom was dating some guy and he
started getting really weird
and he that was his cousin my mom was a
dumbass at the time
and he beat the [ __ ] out of the guy
because he wouldn't leave her alone and
that became her new boyfriend like what
the [ __ ] are you
doing to me my dad was always so mad
like why the
[ __ ] are you miss my kids around these
people but i just thought it was like my
cool step dad you know he plays aggie
sack he's tight
now i get it i'd be pissed because he
went to jail
and that's when i realized that he was
not just some white random white dude
because he was covered in tats i didn't
know what they meant but now when i get
older it's like some american history x
[ __ ]
just just bolts and tattens
and bolts lightning bolts white white
supremist
dude 100 but your mom's jewish
you think i don't [ __ ] know this my
grandma's jewish you know what [ __ ]
man she was
oh just devastated devastated but out of
prison
100 straight edge trying to go to
college race doesn't mean anything
he explained this to me later when he's
in jail he's like when jail it's
different you have to or you're on your
own he explained this to me
he's like now did i need to get this
profile hitler on the background
no i didn't he's straight up it was bad
like white is right real big white is
right
because i asked him what does that mean
and that's when he started explaining to
me like
well and you're in jail what the [ __ ]
you talking about man what are you
talking about mary
i'm [ __ ] nine eight i don't get it i
didn't understand that
people will [ __ ] murk you if you're a
different color i think i knew what
racism was obviously
but yeah prison's got itself it's
different own
it's different country i did world
planet yeah
i didn't know what it was about but i
just knew my stepdad was
this white dude when we go into town we
always get stared at
everywhere we go we get stared at you
know i didn't know
right of course but sure because all the
tablets what did you ever ask your mom
like what the [ __ ] were you thinking
with that guy
i i did a what was this i sat down with
her last year and she's
so good it's kind mainly to piss my mom
off that's what the [ __ ] [ __ ] said
to me
my grandma they didn't have a good
relationship she's like you know what
it's my [ __ ] boyfriend turned into
her [ __ ] husband
the coolest guy in the world i [ __ ]
love that guy he was the [ __ ]
no and that's let me explain to you why
like you like this white supremacist you
piece of [ __ ] let me explain to you
when i met him i didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on we go to visit him in
prison because
we're writing him letters like no my
mom's boy went to jail mom's taking you
to prison to see him too
corcoran and my dad is every [ __ ]
chance he gets is screaming at my mom
and he's just like
he's cool dad leave him alone but little
do i know like why are you taking my
kids to the [ __ ] prison
visiting center so when i first
prison family visits got some bomb-ass
sandwiches let me just say that right
now
i went a few times just to get the
[ __ ] sandwiches
and i'm not kidding at all bro i wake up
at 5 30.
mendocino farms over here
that tri-tip [ __ ] yeah i'm going to see
him today
i swear to god it was anyway
first time i went went to see him i'm
you know i'm excited
it's my step-dad basically i go to see
him
and he looks different he he walks in
different
like he's walking in like slow and i'm
looking i'm like what the [ __ ] is going
on this guy's walking in
not like the guy i know all happy and
fun because he's a fun [ __ ] he's
a genius he's smart as [ __ ] he can draw
anything
in the world he does tattoo he's great
cool guy goes to jail
and then it was just different let's
take a quick break and tell you about
our first sponsor
upstart during these economically
turbulent times everyone's looking for a
way to feel more financially secure so
if you're still needlessly throwing
money
every month at high interest credit card
debt it's time you checked out upstart
the revolutionary online lending
platform that knows you're more
than just a credit score now is the time
to find out how low your upstart rate
can be
to help pay off high interest credit
card debt
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and your job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply though
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online
they offer loans anywhere from a
thousand dollars to fifty thousand
dollars so you can consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment upstart
makes it fast
and simple to check your rate and since
it's just a soft pull it does not affect
your credit score the hard pull happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds
the very next business day over 400 000
people have used upstart to pay off
credit cards or meet their financial
goals
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart
see why upstart has a 4.9 out of 5
rating on trustpilot
and hurry to upstart.com honeydew
to find out how low your upstart rate
can be checking your rate only takes a
few minutes
that's upstart.com honeydew
our next sponsor is tushy now everyone
has an
ass and everyone deserves the gift of
tushy
wiping your butt with dried toilet paper
does not remove
all the [ __ ] if you got poop on any
other part of your body would you just
wipe it with dry paper
no water cleans better than dry paper my
friends
thankfully there's now a sleek bidet
attachment that clips onto your existing
toilet and sprays your butt completely
clean
with fresh water it's called tushy and
it's the best thing you can do for your
butt i use mine all the time it is the
best thing
you can do for your butt tushy sprays
directly to your ass it removes the poop
completely
so you aren't sitting on bacteria that
leads to nasty things like hemorrhoids
yeast infections utis
itchy [ __ ] and skid marks bidets are
common
in the rest of the world a bidet saves
you money on toilet paper
you still need a little bit of toilet
paper to pat yourself dry but the amount
is negligible
it will not clog your toilets and tushy
sprays your ass with
fresh water it's not toilet water it
tushy connects to the water supply
behind your toilet to spray your dirty
parts with clean fresh water it's the
same water you brush your teeth with
wet wipes are worse than toilet paper
they're terrible for the environment
they cause anal fissures and you don't
want your anus
fissuring it's only 79 y'all all right
they also have an ottoman the tushy
ottoman it helps you get everything out
it's like a sexy tooth or cloud
that helps you poop and that's only 69
which is a really good price so here's
the deal
go to hellotushy.com honeydew
and get 10 off your order and free
shipping that's hellotushy.com
honeydew for 10 off your order and free
shipping
now let's get back to the do he walked
in and when he walked in
like everyone looks looks i saw like two
dudes looked down
i know what the [ __ ] is going on and he
walked in hugged us
and then a black dude and the mexican
dude looked over at us
and he looks at him and they both just
look straight down
i mean what the [ __ ] is happening so
there's like a y'all it's like a
family room and there's a concrete slab
brick
room where you can walk around and do
laps with who you're visiting
it's pretty big it's like 30 yards and
we go out as soon as we go out
all the [ __ ] three or four prisoner
dudes get up take their wives go
straight in that
into the visiting room so it's just us
out there
so me i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
like nobody wants to be around us like
is this full sick
what do i do we're walking with you and
then when you pass the guards i see the
guards like look at him and look away
and i'm just trying to figure it out i
don't get it and i asked my mom
his head shaved at this point he had
long hair still long here
all the way down to his knees like far
he had [ __ ]
the longest hair and then he i'll get to
that
um i asked my mom like why is everybody
sitting down
why does everybody leave when we go
around they look straight at the floor
when we walk by
and why are we you know i mean when i
walked in everybody's staring at like
what the [ __ ] are you here to see
my sister's dark i'm not yeah brown my
sister's darker than i am you are not
listening to this ain't no way the king
of the white walkers is coming over here
to hug the brown [ __ ] [ __ ]
at all man and i have seen the pictures
now like little
little fat little kid with him smiling
like what the [ __ ] is going on
so i asked my mom and she just says
nothing she didn't tell me [ __ ] so he
gets out two three years later i'm older
i'm like 12.
my mom and him get married or a year or
two later they get married
um they end up having a babe but the
baby didn't make it
like eight or eight months ish um
but it's my stepdad he's going to all
these places trying to get
a teaching degree in engineering because
he's got all these degrees from being
he'd been in prison i didn't know this
19 years of his life he's 35.
holy [ __ ] your mom's having a baby he's
going to prison
16. wild right
so what was he in for okay so the fir
the first things he tells me he gets he
was doing like robberies with his
friends
and he went to jail on his 18th birthday
and got transferred right to the big
the big house he basically said i went
to the i went i had to be around growing
men in my 18th birthday
and he told me some crazy things but
that's why they don't say his name
because
he's back in jail but they're not
together they haven't been together for
12
15 years no almost 20 [ __ ] years they
haven't been together
and um he's told me some crazy [ __ ] man
like being a kid like pretty blue-eyed
kid at 18 not hard at all yet not scary
he's told me some when they were
starting divorce i started going with
him on the weekend like it was like my
dad my dad was never [ __ ] around
so your dad would just get mad that you
guys were around guys like this but he
would never show up when
yeah once or twice maybe every two three
[ __ ] months [ __ ] you doing breaking
my kids riding these little always
working
i ain't coming but get some new guys in
here goddamn
exactly i'm just happy he showed the
[ __ ] up i'm hyped
we'd do anything and it'd be fun you
know but uh he was always working my
dad's non-stop
truck driving never not worked goes to
school all that [ __ ] he's just
on one and if he doesn't want to be
around us all [ __ ] on
he just doesn't show up but he did a lot
so piss me the [ __ ] off
so this my stepdad was like my dad he i
lifted weights with him he
showed me stuff like you know we live
with them so
i'm about 12 or 13 they're getting a
divorce they're not it's not going
because you started doing meth
this [ __ ] guy started doing meth and
[ __ ]
i didn't care or no i just knew they
were getting divorced so i go out in the
country to those moms way out in the
[ __ ] boonies
the lady you know those older white
ladies that survive on
cigs and pepsi only diet pepsi you know
cigarettes and planters peanuts anything
almost yeah
my mom's mom was like that i'm like well
do you eat grandma
nothing i just survived sugar cigarettes
diet coke and [ __ ] planters peanuts
you know exactly what i'm saying
that was the meal yeah every now and
then like a tasty
like a like a [ __ ] hostess of
something yeah yeah yeah a coffee cake
yeah yeah a snowball yeah that was one
of my girls yeah
so we went up to his mom's that's that
lady and she comes out like
super hick out of a trailer all right
sick we're staying here the weekends
look and i go in they're nice great so
me and him camp out in the country
for two days and he's just telling me
all this
[ __ ] because he's like you know what in
case we don't i'm still your dad
you know because i've known him for six
seven years
and um that's when he starts telling me
about all the prison [ __ ] and why
everybody wouldn't look around
and um so basically he said
18th birthday he knew he had to do some
[ __ ] 18th birthday he walked into
[ __ ] prison
and he's like no dude i'm small he's not
a big guy but when my mom met him
he's a [ __ ] like the most shredded
person on the planet like just
like [ __ ] american history actually
on i think my mom just like my mom loves
edward norton she's obsessed with him
like
do you just have a crush on [ __ ]
white people because you don't have to
get the nazi [ __ ] yeah you don't have to
do
that the [ __ ] wrong i talk [ __ ] to her
every day
every time i see her just
i don't hold a grudge but i'm gonna talk
[ __ ] to you every time i talk about it
it's i love it she's gonna get so
[ __ ] pissed about this
but it's great um he's just a shredded
[ __ ]
but not as a kid so he told me i'm a
skinny [ __ ] kid i was
doing robbery i wasn't fighting people
and he tells me
that like the best thing you can do when
you get to jail if you're not if you
want to be down but you're scared
go stab a rapist or go get a pedophile
just [ __ ]
them up so i'll do whatever you can in
front of somebody
and you're okay you're gonna get talked
to some somebody's gonna get talked to
have you come out of a hole
and he said straight up he walked up to
the guy with his
little plastic fork and just started
stabbing the guy in the neck but he said
he was like he saw it was a chester so i
didn't give a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] does that mean he
explained that chester's like a molester
yeah
[ __ ] and i tell them that's [ __ ] sad
that's mean why would you
stab somebody over that like you know as
a kid
i'm super nice i don't like to fight i
[ __ ] you up i just don't want to f i
don't want to do that
you know what i mean you don't ever want
to hurt people ever talk it out
but when he told me that i'm looking at
him in a whole different light like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
you just stab the man in the throat he
goes yeah i just till it try to open up
and they
pulled me off but as i he said as i'm
leaving
all these mexican fools are like looking
at me like [ __ ] yeah
because he spoke fluent spanish and this
makes sense why
you don't actually know why he's with my
mom
it's white supremacy spanish speaks
fluent fluent spanish man
it's almost just like a cartoon right
and you know you got the skin color and
everything
see oh come on you had a white
supremacist trying to teach you spanish
[Laughter]
[Music]
yo saying this [ __ ] out loud is so much
different than just thinking about it
it's different listen living it is all
different when you start talking about
it man
yeah i guess yeah he did try to teach me
spanish
okay so wait he goes in oh yeah
they're pulling them off he's going in
to set a precedent like look i'm going
to go after the
the piece of [ __ ] we all don't like
anyway exactly let you all know i'm not
a [ __ ] i'm down i'm here
well that's what he's explaining to me
and i'm telling like are you [ __ ]
kidding me because i'm
so nice especially y'all don't gotta
worry about me i ain't gonna say [ __ ] he
always told me through my time
tell me don't ever go to jail he always
like you're too [ __ ] nice please
don't ever go to jail that's all you
used to tell me
scared the [ __ ] out of me i mean going
to see him for years in prison so why
are they looking down why are they
scared of them or is it just a respect
thing what was it oh so this is what i'm
building up to he told me and he told me
when you get older i'll tell you the
rest because i was only 12 or 13. he
said when you get older i'll tell you
the rest
but by the time i was 14 he was gone
like back in prison
this is meth and just like running
around town then now he's back so
you know but he told me when you get
older i'll tell you the rest of it but
he told me stabbing that [ __ ] man in
the neck and it
grossed me the [ __ ] out he showed me how
to throw knives he's telling me the
story as he's showing me how to practice
to throw knives
i'm really good at throwing knives from
that weekend i'm really good at it
randomly like how to balance it show me
how to balance it here and you can
oh what the [ __ ] would you learn this
[ __ ] at man
teaching me prison moves [ __ ] 12
years old but
we're in the country he's like let me
show you how to make homemade flour
tortillas
no he he did he did [ __ ] like that he
did [ __ ] like that
he made weird foods like with random
spread like jellies
yeah because he's a prisoner yeah he
would make like jellies like toast and
weird [ __ ] on it
give him some toothpaste and some
shoelaces i'll make some waffles in
right here in a minute
those prisoners can do anything man he
could draw us
right now i mean tell him he's he's a
talented [ __ ] man when you have
nothing to do i guess you
you figure out some [ __ ] all right so go
ahead i'm sorry
no you're fine you're fine um so he was
what did he build himself up
oh so he's telling me basically the
ranks i know what he was trying to tell
me without telling me because he's i'm a
kid and i know what he's [ __ ] saying
i've seen movies well not stupid
he's telling me basically i write out
plans in these books this book right
here tells you how to do this this this
so he basically told me i used to plan
things and
when people need to get stabbed where
people need in the talking about within
the yeah he just
like basically draws matt he's an
engineer she's like i draw i get the
blueprint this is where you're gonna
have him here this is notice this
and you tell him he's like i basically
planned i planned people getting hurt
and that's how he said i plan to people
getting hurt but in the game like so
you're stabbed [ __ ] this is
what you're trying to tell me you're
killing people in jail [ __ ]
that he didn't tell me but i knew what
the [ __ ] he was he literally
sketched out that's what he said he used
to he's like basically draw it out to
where
you don't know where it's at he doesn't
know where the weapon's at and it's over
because a lot of people get killed in
jail that aren't even on the news you
know that
i believe it a lot of [ __ ] people get
murked in jail and you
don't even hear about it on the news the
[ __ ] he's told me is
unreal in jail just
like what stands out right this is the
one that got me because he
i don't know if it's real but he always
had this like little diamond earring and
he always had it he always said yeah i
found this in jail he always used to say
that i found this in jail
and that trip were camping he told me
what happened he said this black dude
had life and he was real young
and he said he wasn't down he was
getting beat up and the [ __ ] guy
jumped in front of
one of the trucks that come to get the
trash and he said i saw this guy's head
just pop
oh he killed himself because he wasn't
gonna yeah well he's got life as a
little he's
19 years old and he's like this he said
people do it all the time
people kill themselves all the [ __ ]
time because they can't handle it in
there
i understand oh yeah it's [ __ ] sad
but i'm 12 and i'm trying to figure out
you
take me to the movies man what the [ __ ]
you talking about you kill [ __ ]
he didn't say it though he never said he
killed anybody except
he knows better than that to tell a kid
yeah i murdered people he never said
that he always said i plan on people
getting hurt
or and he said i stabbed him in the neck
he didn't die that's what he told me so
he saw this this kid jumping he said he
saw it and then he said when he went
over there he had
two little diamonds in his teeth and
he's like i picked up his tooth put it
you know i put it in my pocket put him
in his ass he put in his [ __ ] ass
and then he said and here it is and i
think that's not true i'm telling you
that's not true it can't be [ __ ] true
that's disgusting you rock
gross [ __ ] so um yeah that that
was him
he was a wild man dude so many so many
instances with him like
around town just saying in prison white
supremacists
outside of prison not my best friend was
black growing up uh
named justin his dad is the head
detective of our town
i mean do you watch ufc yeah do you
remember marvin beastman eastman
i i don't oh he's a small well beastman
eastman his older brother
is who i'm talking about okay from
merced and his six-four
monster he gets out of jail we get a
house
right next to my best friend and i'm
[ __ ] hyped like he's my best friend
he's down the street two blocks away
i go over there with him with my stepdad
and his dad's outside and it's just
stared down they just start looking at
each other he's like i just don't like
jews
oh get the [ __ ] i don't like jews you
are fine
my wife's jewish but other than that i
don't like any other
no no no this is the thing he explained
it to me habla says about y'all
no everybody speaks spanish
even the white supremacists everybody
[ __ ] speaks man i need to learn
that's literally when everybody uses the
term everyone speaks and
that is the if he is speaking spanish
you don't have an excuse
flea market's no problem getting talking
them down
yep
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] um
[ __ ] oh yeah so walk
he's they stare at each other staring at
each other
and they go talk to each other by the by
my friend's dad's car i mean my friend
justin
just with the footballs what what the
[ __ ] is happening here
two minutes later they walk away and
they're smiling everything's fine
because they know each other
my stepdad is a [ __ ] criminal they
know each other he's a detective but he
wasn't always he was a police officer
they know exactly who each other are so
when we go home and go hey what happened
says i mean haven't been in a few fights
we know each other
everything's fine i'm like damn that
[ __ ] you fought
him because i've heard stories about my
stepdad beating the [ __ ] out of people
and my family has seen him like just
randomly so i don't
doubt that he's kicking people and he's
a big fan of hanukkah you know
not at all but he's i mean no more weeks
it's very it's it's he always told me
race doesn't matter out here
he's like your best friend's black right
he's like i love him he's like my son
doesn't matter in jail whole different
[ __ ] story and that's why he said
when people look down it's because they
know not to [ __ ] look at me with my
brown ass kids
that's what it was like don't [ __ ]
say anything i could only imagine what
happened
after you know after the [ __ ]
visiting hour is over because i can see
him
down the hall through the glass door
getting uncuffed
and he doesn't have the same face he has
when he walks into the room
you know like he looks like a scary
[ __ ] walks out
and says what's up called my mom and
[ __ ] i go get sandwiches and you know
what i'm saying
that was it um he's just
it's a weird time because he raised me
with my mom my dad
was there periodically but he was always
pissed about it it
turned out so nice you did you turned
out so kind it's because
i don't want to hurt people man yeah
that's not fun like that's enough i've
been in a very few fights and all of
them
were not my fault you know i didn't
start that [ __ ]
ever um but he showed me how to box and
barely retained any of that [ __ ] i don't
i don't remember any of it
but he's a scary ass dude but very cool
dude
what about um is it your uncle do you
accidentally had this uh
okay smoke session with so you're i just
want to reset for a second so you're
introduced to
quite a bit at a very early age from
drugs to split family to
domestic violence to prison to white
supremacy
clearly not introduced to
spanish-speaking people my whole
family's not spanish but
uh my whole family you didn't grow up i
thought my mom raised me
oh my mom's jewish side so you too
don't speak spanish my sister speaks
spanish she retained that [ __ ]
because they were together since she was
like five but i was only like three
i didn't so you and your mom don't speak
spanish everyone else does
my whole my dad my grandma my stepdad
yeah everybody everybody dude the dog on
that side
but my mom's side they're all like
marcias and ron's and
chains anomalies and emily's exactly
loretta's
gotcha so that's why the other ones are
[ __ ] carlos and [ __ ]
they all speak spanish they all speak
spanish
they're ready to hide me out there i'll
be the [ __ ] christmas i'll just sit
there
just [ __ ] man what are you guys talking
about [ __ ]
but my cousin's my age we all just you
know english first but it's like
growing up like that [ __ ] they all look
at me thomas and my cousins are talking
to me what the [ __ ] are you saying bro
you won't play football
what do you want to do it's thanksgiving
i don't want to talk to you i it's very
aggravating man
it's my fault i need to learn so when
outside of seeing the cocaine outside of
knowing what your parents are doing with
the meth and everything
when does drug when do drugs enter your
world
your body oh okay the day before the
raiders got
their asses whooped by the bucks in the
super bowl remember that actually
12 000 [ __ ] interceptions the night
before that
my sister how old are you 13. okay
my sister i smoked trash weed out of a
mountain toucan with her and then i
watched mad tv and then saturday night
live
and i drank so much tampico juice and
that was the first time i ever remember
tampie what is that really shitty
mexican juice
it's really bad like homemade no it's
from the store it's a dollar for a
gallon
it's not good but i drink the whole
[ __ ] thing right
um but before that was anti-drug
everything i got i've had straight a's
i played football play sports math
student of the year [ __ ]
but i started smoking weed and i got my
first b and that's when it all went bad
i never got over one point anything
again no
because i didn't give a [ __ ] i was
always in the gifted programs
like the [ __ ] nerd kids i was in
all those classes because i lived in the
ghetto but i had to go to the nice part
of town to go to my classes
for elementary study on a bus and none
of my friends were there
you know um so drugs started with my
sister it was just wheat
just weed i started smoking weed heavy
in eighth grade
because that's when it happened after
the raiders and
it just kind of just got too it just
it's fun
you smoke weed now i smoke weed now i
didn't until i was
i got a late start i went first ever
tried it was 18
uh a kid rolled a joint i took one hit
the whole joint broke in my mouth he was
like just [ __ ] eat it because he
didn't have a rope so i ate it so that
was
i didn't even i can't even say i smoked
it i didn't smoke it i ate that joint
was your first experience
first ever experience second time was a
few months later to
we were at a backyard party and i went
to take it off a bowl but it was already
ashed
so and then again i didn't do it till i
was 21.
wow yeah good for you that's [ __ ]
awesome i got in there late
that's great but i think also at the
right time i
don't know if i'd have been the same
person if i just started smoking weed at
13 14 or whatever no no i know what you
mean but
my mom like i said nobody ever knew i
smoked weed because she will [ __ ]
stab me
you know what i'm saying she'll [ __ ] me
up so i smoked with my sister
ninth grade comes and still playing
football and then
10th grade this is where it all changed
for me i'm smoking bowls of my friends
putting in five dollars we're trying to
smoke bowls before football games you
know smoking out of cans and
[ __ ] and uh i'll never forget it man
i
i bought a i bought a 10 sack of weed
from this guy at school with 10th grade
like the first week of school
and i had a 10 sack of weed my [ __ ]
i'm gonna get high as [ __ ] today
and this random girl i knew came up to
me and asked me if i knew where to get
wheat
and like the [ __ ] my brain split and
said just [ __ ] sell half of it to her
for ten dollars
and make your money back sold half of it
to her another girl came up another dude
came up to me and asked me for a 15
i just yeah it's already way down i made
25
off ten dollars and i stared at it
i looked around for my friend my best
friend joe at the time that's why i
would smoke weed with
and i told him the situation he didn't
believe me look at the money i only had
ten dollars
we bought an ounce after school that day
bagged it up where where are you getting
an ounce back this guy named sam
he's an older guy plays football he had
really trash well i thought it was great
he had really bad weed he sold us an
ounce like 250
back then we got played it was like 150
at the time
anyway we got the sack and me and joe
looked at each other like we don't have
a scale we can't
ask anybody to buy us a scale we're
gonna eyeball this [ __ ]
so we got plastic wrap and made our own
little bags well yeah that's about 10
bucks like that's about 20.
and then i'm super cautious because my
mom will [ __ ] me
up so i'm not gonna get caught with weed
at all ever
nothing let's take a quick break and
tell you about our next sponsor
keeps two out of three guys will
experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 and the best way to prevent
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still have hair left you used
to have to go to the doctor's office for
your hair loss prescription now
thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medication
delivered
right to your home they make it easy and
they deliver your medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits all right
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there you may have tried them before
but probably never for this price
prevention is key
keeps treatments can take up to four to
six months or more to see results so
it's important to act fast and the
sooner you start using keeps
the more hair you'll save find out why
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors and nearly a
hundred thousand men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication
keeps his treatment start at just ten
dollars a month
plus for a limited time you can get your
first month for free alright so here's
what you got to do
if you're if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss
go to keeps.com honeydew to receive your
first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash honeydew keeps.com slash
honeydew our next sponsor is manscaped
who
is the best in men's below the belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
they obsess over their technology
developments
to provide you the best tools for your
grooming experience look i've talked
about it before
i definitely manscape and i've used some
other uh
equipment before and i mean my balls
have been bloody my taint's been
tattered like it is
it's no joke down there you get some
skin caught in that razor
good night irene all right so manscaped
has redesigned the electric trimmer the
manscaped engineering team spent 18
months perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer
ever created and just released the new
and improved lawnmower 3.0 their third
generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce manscaping accidents
thanks to manscape's advanced skills
technology when i tell you this is
premium i mean it's premium the battery
will last up to 90 minutes so you can
take a longer shave
the water resistant technology allows
you to groom in the shower
one of the coolest features a little led
light which illuminates the grooming
areas so you can get a closer more
precise trimming
uh and let's not forget about the
charging stand this one comes with a
charging stand you can show your mower
off loud and proud
uh because this intelligent design stand
uh it's a convenient charging dock
powered by
usb all right so if you're listening to
me speak right now i want you to
experience it firsthand for yourself
trim that junk of yours get 20 off plus
free shipping
with the code honeydew at manscaped.com
your balls will thank you all right
that's 20 off
and free shipping with the code honeydew
at manscaped.com
now let's get back to the do so it made
me become like a little
[ __ ] little piece of [ __ ] honestly
because
on sunday i went to school and stashed
it all over school
my whole ounce like i put some in the
wood shop what yeah cause i'm not gonna
carry it
right but this is where you're putting
it you're keeping it that's what i did
drain pipes because at the bottom they
have that little piece of metal inside
so i just put it in the drain pipe
underneath and put in the drain pop
how many bags do you think 30. 30
scattered bags
all around school yeah first day first
lunch sold every [ __ ] bag
me and joe sold every bat he's super
pretty in middle school
no no uh 10th grade is 10th grade first
like
week of 10th grade and it was the most
fun i ever had
me and him he wanted to carry it on him
but my mom will [ __ ] kill me if she
finds out i have wheat smoke weed and
i'm selling weed
it's over i'm i'm like i said she'll
knock me unconscious
this before she punched me in the face
and i realized she ain't [ __ ] because
that's when i realized like that you
know hurt
but i was still scared so we stashed it
all over school
metal uh wood shop has all the wood
pallets outside so i stashed it like
okay
three steps put your arm in three steps
put your arm in
yeah so that's how we did it every day
man every day for how long
like six months until sam couldn't get
wheat anymore and then we're just like
all right
so you did it because you couldn't get
weed anymore not because now i was
smoking free
and i stopped because i couldn't get the
good weed anymore and then it got to
well i spent all that re-up money on
drugs and alcohol
i guess i'll get a ten sec and then we
found it in the connection we started
selling weed again
that's really what happened in the
school yeah [ __ ] i would go up to every
group
uh you need weed living i'd walk away
you need weed living but look at me i
don't look like i have weed it looks so
nice and just polite
and you didn't know these kids i [ __ ]
knew everybody just hold me down
okay and if i got in trouble i know who
the [ __ ] did it right i went to all
those groups i'm gonna go see who's
looking at me weird and that's you
but no i but i would never have wheat on
me i always had money on me
because they'd like me 15 like go and
get it from the drain pipe and
that's it it was really really good man
it worked a lot it worked well but um
oh you would send them to go get it no i
don't want them to know my spots are
yeah okay because when you say go get it
from the drain
you're telling them okay oh [ __ ] no just
go get it not pay me
hell no um and then i one thing that
scared the [ __ ] of us we stopped
selling at school the drug dogs always
came they always get our schools [ __ ]
merced
they search the lockers and walk around
our school touch all the backpacks with
the dogs
while we're learning and [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] up but
i mean i wasn't paying attention but you
know what i mean um
somebody told me the drug dogs there was
a metal shop and i'm in [ __ ] metal
shop where am i gonna hide this weed
i have an ounce of weed in a bag in
sacks
and i ran to the metal shop bathroom and
i just [ __ ] taped it to behind the
toilet and i just
sat there drug dogs came i just sat
there scared just petrified man
god never brought it to school again i
was too scared did they find it
[ __ ] no they didn't so they probably
weren't even weed dogs they're probably
looking for harder [ __ ]
i think if anybody did walk the dogs and
any kid that did this
they were gonna search that's really
what it was they came a lot
our school sucks man our school [ __ ]
sucks um
but that's when i started selling weed
it was fun fun times
so yeah let's talk about selling weed
because
you didn't you sold a lot of weed when i
got older when i got older i started
selling
a lot of [ __ ] weed like to wear i was
nervous
um i was breaking down pounds so i would
probably get rid of like five or six
pounds every
two days probably days yeah but like in
sacks like oh you want an ounce oh you
want an ounce oh you want an ounce i had
a dispensary basically at my house
my cousin my older cousin came to my
house to visit me for the first time and
he's 15 years older than me so he sees
me as a little kid
oh you smoke weed let me come to your
house i had 15 [ __ ] people in a line
in my house waiting for like a
dispensary before we had dispensaries
and nobody was robbing home invasions
they go oh and the guy below i moved to
this apartment my friend jebus
the man below me sold meth i could tell
right off the [ __ ] back because he
was twacked out four people came to his
house and left
but oh so you're still meth i know what
meth is my family does bad
so i knew exactly right off the bat he's
the groundskeeper
i know he ain't gonna tell me i'm
telling your stupid ass you're selling
meth [ __ ]
so he lived below me so everybody that
came into the little
hallway looks like they're going to his
house but they're just coming to get
weed for me and leave
and they're all my friends and no one's
allowed to bring anybody over
that was my thing they're all my friends
small town later on it got to where
i moved because [ __ ] were gonna
try to rob me that's when i
realized like [ __ ] man these are no
longer just my friends now people
know but i was on the internet and
that's why they knew so i started
i stopped selling weed when my page got
started getting bigger and stuff
because because you were advertising on
the internet no
not never advertise to sale a week
because i'm not a jerk
i'm not gonna like hey cops take that
into court me selling wheat on the
[ __ ] internet
but no it's been over seven years that's
why i talk about the [ __ ] freely i
thought you said you had the picture you
got taken down
ago but you did that on the internet
right yeah but i wasn't selling the
wheat anymore
oh oh it was after god all my friends
are
they're massive grows legal grows god
grows so hey
i'll do this picture today do you have a
hundred pounds of wheat and now it's 200
pounds
but when i was 19-ish i was
i was selling pounds a week like that
but it was more
i would never post on the internet i
didn't start doing the internet until i
was 22.3
so before that is when all the [ __ ] was
going on i didn't have a [ __ ]
smartphone
i was a drug i don't want a smartphone i
had a little [ __ ] cricket phone i
paid 20
a month i threw it away every so often
you know um but in a small town
there's not a lot of fireweed so
everybody kind of knows who the
fireweed's coming from and that's when
it got to be
like okay [ __ ] now you now you guys know
what's going on because i should sell
i used to deliver pizza i always had a
job because i'm not dumb i don't want to
get my door kicked in
so i used to sell weed out of my pizza
car because i used to deliver pizza
so people would text me i'd put my scale
my weed in my pizza bag
i walk up to their door walk in sell
them weed leave everybody thinks i'm
selling pizza
there's no [ __ ] pizza in the bag it
was the best time i ever had i made more
money
at work doing pizza than any time in my
whole life the customers just come to
you my whole life man
um i get paid for the gas they pay me
for my time
and gas man i'm walking i would just
roll around my pizza car smoke bowls and
right when i get to the
with a real pizza delivery i'd open the
pizza box and do that and it'd smell
like pizza everywhere
i'd walk up no weed i'd open the box to
them so they don't i never got trouble
for smoking nothing
but i smoked 30 bowls of [ __ ] day you
know riding around selling weed and
pizza it was
it was the best thing it was better than
the school thing like that was easy this
is easy i get paid
to ride around nobody pulls over the
pizza guy man
no no i keep my sign on after work all
the time and sell sex
every day i would just keep it on at all
the time nobody pulls you i got pulled
over once
one time because my tail light was out
in four years you know and no problem
nobody and i bought my manager his mom
smokes weeds i'd sell her weed so he's
not going to tell on me
you know i would just get high and i did
my job so it was the most
fun i've ever had and then i was leaving
a delivery
and i hear these there's a [ __ ]
merced i know i know getting
i know if you're affiliated i know if
you're a northerner i could see it on
you i know where you're at
i hear these fools as i'm pulling away
that's that fool that sells pizza a weed
out of his car
and i heard it and you heard that [ __ ]
all right you fools know about this this
is not good anymore
and i quit like three weeks later but it
wasn't because of that but i remember
hearing that made me like re-evaluate
everything
because i've almost gotten robbed many
times i'm sure yeah no
just for people for the yeah and now
that we got all my weed in my car and
that would have been the worst to take
all my weed this apartment we lived in
in baltimore
we we didn't know it until we moved in
but we ordered a pizza from papa john's
and they're like where do you live we
give the address like oh no man we don't
deliver there after dark we're like what
damn oh in baltimore
after dark oh they're getting robbed
left and right yeah
yeah that's what happened to me that
people were getting robbed a lot almost
i was on a pizza delivery my manager
that week told us the whole thing
two pizza people in merced small town i
got robbed at gunpoint already
one got his ass whooped because he
didn't give up his [ __ ] money bag
there's only twenty dollars in that
[ __ ] money bag man yeah what's wrong
with you he had his ass whooped another
lady just got robbed at gunpoint
so i go to uh i go to loft bro it's a
bad street in my town
i go to loughborough i pull them to the
house and there are
four to four or five dudes and all just
you could tell
all men in prison all just got the [ __ ]
out because they're still rocked out
you know there's a couple of skinny meth
head looking dudes with them too but
two or three of the guys were [ __ ]
big i'm not i can't
i'll try but i'm not going to be able to
win nothing weird they just looked at me
when i pulled up on my pizza
pulled up it's apartment it's an
apartment uh like
condos so there's one door two door
three door all flat you know and one big
block
so they're one next to me i walk up to
the to the one next to him
hello you know me and the pizza bag just
trying to be nice
high [ __ ] knock on the door
just wait nothing happens i knock on the
[ __ ] door i look at these guys and
they're all just staring at me like this
they're all looking at me like [ __ ] i
know that look [ __ ] please open the door
like
come on and i knock on the door and as i
knock on the door i'm looking and
one of the blinds is kind of open and
there's nothing in the [ __ ] apartment
it's completely empty nobody in there
and i click like these fools called the
pizza
[ __ ] uh i wanted to just like just run
away but my car is right there with a
key
you know i'm not getting away it's a
cul-de-sac by the way it's cold i'm not
getting away there's a creek on the
other side it's i'm done
as soon as i realized like [ __ ] i don't
look over and i can
already like hear them walking and they
walk onto the lawn
two guys start walking behind me and i
turn around like hey what's up
[ __ ] man and i was ready to go here
take it [ __ ] that car you want the car
that car sucks take it i am not getting
jumped by all you guys today
i got [ __ ] to do i haven't you know i
mean i don't want to do this it's [ __ ]
this job
they all two guys get next to me right
here three dudes here
i was like [ __ ] what's up two dudes the
skinniest dudes walk toward me the
littlest guys walk toward me
and as they do i'm ready to go here i'm
just waiting for him to say something
like nope i don't want it take my money
[ __ ] you it's not my money
and as i do as i'm about to take my bag
off my shoulder
my [ __ ] friend from uh city league
football he's like he's a gang banging
ass fool
he went a different route i'm nice he
went to the stabby route you know
he comes out of the [ __ ] apartment
they're in and i just oh my god thank
god
i don't know if he's gonna jump me too
but at least i know who you are and
we're
good friends i haven't seen you in years
because you're [ __ ] gangbanging he's
older than me
i don't chill with you i'm good he walks
out and as he sees me you see his face
go oh
and he walks and splits the guys goes
hey thomas what's up puts his arm on my
shoulder goes what's up
what's going on jerry we start walking
he's like hey man how are you doing you
should probably go let's go
all right go yeah you get out of here
get out of here man right now i'm like
oh man good to see you
i knew what he was saying i knew exactly
what he was doing well thanks man good
to see you yeah they're not here
those fools are crazy man they're never
even here that's what he said oh
they always do that [ __ ] he said it like
yeah the pizza thing i can see him doing
this
i know what he's doing he's like yo
don't stab my friend please like i could
see it on his face like yo
get in my car later man i'm trying to
play nice like later dude
i turn around as i turn around he's
talking to all of them like [ __ ]
jerry
thank you
i'm not going to let you just punch me
in the face i'm going to start swinging
then i'm going to downswing then i'm
going to make it jump yeah you know let
me get my ass whooped
i'm going out fighting i ain't going out
like yeah i'm not i'm i'm gonna give you
myself if i'm gonna go
out why would i not like get a couple in
you can have my stuff but if you start
hitting me then i have to sweat
but it's [ __ ] jerry man i saw him
four years later
i was in merced i was at a stoplight i
wasn't working the pizza spot
and this cadillac rolls up and no one's
driving the [ __ ]
and this [ __ ] gangster ass pulls up
he's laying all the way back in his car
like a [ __ ] straight stereotype
gangster hey what's up man
what's up jerry just tatted
everywhere like just gang [ __ ] all over
his face but that's my friend as a kid
you know that's my friends that came
with my stepdad that time with justin we
were all
good friends play football together so
seeing him and then seeing he had three
kids with them
they all looked happy as [ __ ] but you're
a gang banging ass fool but you're still
awesome
and just seeing him completely tatted on
his face and then thinking about him as
a kid it was just
what a change up you hung out with those
guys i know those guys
that's all it took what the [ __ ] is that
crazy wow
man i gotta it but he saved my life
i really thought they were gonna [ __ ]
just kill me they also
and i'm not small you're gonna punch me
in the face and try to beat the [ __ ] out
of me
it was it was a it was scary i'm scary
as [ __ ] i told my boss didn't believe me
[ __ ] [ __ ] didn't even [ __ ]
believe that's great we got two
pepperonis that need to get out now
um tell me the story about the first
time uh
you smoked uh crack drugs
yeah so my first dabble into drugs was
accidental
right okay no another one so
when you're 14 15 you're drinking
smoking weed right you're not really
doing coke yet
well maybe you were but i hit the coke
heavy around 16.
and we're so early yeah 14 15. but it's
more sad we're bored yeah
nothing to have kids no i'll just do
drugs you know that's all we do there
and i'm at my friend nate's house we go
there every mom's a
paramedic so she works night shifts so
that's nate saturday sunday we have to
be out by 6 00 a.m
but we can come over at five in the
afternoon and we get [ __ ] up all night
clean up and leave
every weekend for two years straight so
this weekend we go over there and
there's
[ __ ] girls outside smoking out of a
wee pipe with this guy ryan i know
i know this girl's in sixth grade
there's smoke we're 14.
you expect wheat i'm i have wheat in my
pocket i'm like yo i'll pack a bowl you
don't get packed
and i get it and she goes it's a cabbie
i don't know what the [ __ ] that means
see that fate
i never heard that one but i'm lighting
it it's okay like i'm [ __ ] with that
cabbage patch kid like i don't know what
the [ __ ] she's talking about like
yeah i hit it i start smoking it and as
i start hitting it
i feel it like deep in my chest and i
let it out and i go
nothing's coming out nothing's coming
out and then a cloud out of nowhere like
that's not eat smoke have you ever seen
people smoke meth in person
not meth no math in person it's like a
cloud that sits it's like a heavy cloud
it doesn't dissipate it like
and then it goes away so when i let it
out
i just felt my head just go so your
first drug experience it was meth
there's this [ __ ] i go what the [ __ ] is
in that [ __ ] it's a cabbie boy i told
you
what does that mean there's chris on it
and i just wanted to
punch her in the [ __ ] head so it's
weed with meth
had chris on it like a bunch of crystal
it was packed but when i'm smoking
it i don't know that right in high
school you never roast the whole bowl
you hit corners corners corners so it's
really kind of black
i'm like oh i'm hit that [ __ ] but when
she try to warm me tell me the [ __ ]
name of the drug
you [ __ ] i'm not a tweaker why do i
know your slang terms right
right um that's daffodil exactly
what's that's all that's what we call
heroin here like wait what's a flower
um so i started puking because i was
real drunk off uh tangare
mm-hmm tangerine and uh orange uh clear
kool-aid
it was nasty um what happened was i
started feeling like my skin was itchy
everywhere i started feeling like uh
like i was rolling grass all hot and you
know yeah oh yeah
that's how i felt i felt like uh i
couldn't control every thought i had i
wasn't really high
but it made me a little like wired
enough to start throwing up and i just
started
just puking every puke my guts out first
time i ever did hard drugs and that was
an accident
[ __ ] that girl she pissed me off [ __ ]
her
anyway uh the incident you're talking
about me and my uncle john
this is uh my uncle john's about
12 years older than me right he's my
aunt's husband so he's not worried about
my blood i met him at 10
he was 20 21. so when i get 14 15 i
didn't know he could just get high and
then he finds out i could say you won't
smoke weed together
now thinking back like why are you
smoking with a 14 year old kid man
for real what's wrong with you but this
is my uncle man that's my [ __ ] home
i love that guy and he always just say
i'm never putting a powder up my nose
because i started doing coke and he he
was so mad
because we smoke weed and get drunk
together and drink high lives and [ __ ]
and he was so [ __ ] mad you're 15.
stop doing cold
he was so mad about it while he's
smoking weed with with weaving
smoke weed man like this is what we do
why are you doing [ __ ] lines
you said stop doing lines you should say
that to me go you would love it if you
tried it
i told him it's like it's amazing what
are you talking about
and you say i've never put something up
my nose until one [ __ ] day
we're drinking and i finally got him to
do a line you did
just beating him down he's fine no no i
had it and he just
all right i'm gonna try that [ __ ] he
went
oh and then he went oh and then i got i
chopped him one up
and i have created a monster that day he
loved coke so [ __ ] much it got to
where i'd come over
if i got a sack why do you have a sack
oh i got
brandon's number why do you have my
[ __ ] coat dealers number
guy like you gave it to me that night
[ __ ] i was drunk
but when i gave him the dealer's number
he lived three blocks away
and it and he's an adult he has a job he
can afford it i was a kid
i was getting coke every four days with
my friends so
he's getting a bunch of coke months
months months we're doing lines it was
[ __ ] awesome um and he started
putting coke on his weed of bowls and
smoking it
like why that's nasty i told him i'm not
going to do that
so i'm drinking highlights with him it's
nighttime but it's cocoa power
cocoa puffs really i never i never tried
this girl
it's always the chicks that would
introduce me to the new yeah put she's
like we used to put coke on our wheat
i'm like why
it's stupid does it get you nuts it
doesn't do nothing
it [ __ ] you i feel like you just burn
it up yeah crack once
now yeah so we're standing outside by
his washer and dryer where we always do
[ __ ] lines at and i watch for my aunt
[Laughter]
all right we would pretend to play
basketball
so as he's chopping to play fast
play basketball means you won't do lines
in the shed that's what it meant like
you went to lines in the shed and we had
a candle light because there was no
light
so we're [ __ ] addicts just [ __ ]
those
15 16. having a great time sad and
romantic
it was fun man it was fun um but this is
how the crack thing happened
he got a sack and he starts putting on a
ball i tell him no i don't want to do it
i don't want to do it he just got a coke
sack that's all i know it's in the dark
we don't have a [ __ ] light
like all right [ __ ] so i start roasting
it i remember where i was standing when
i
started roasting it and looking at it
like
and as i smoke it you know when people
burn plastic to make that's what it
smells like it smells like burning
plastic
but it was in my nose like in my brain i
could taste
the smell i let it out and i just got
like
a searing headache in both sides of my
temples like it was
shoving and i looked at him what the
[ __ ] did you just give me
he goes it's coke and i looked at a sack
15 minutes later we're doing a line
man it's all yellow rocks crushed up he
got a [ __ ] crack
didn't check the bag sprinkled it all
over the bowl and i'm just started going
in on him
like no come on [ __ ] you're
talking [ __ ]
you know i mean to give him the lecture
like you didn't check your [ __ ] sack
there was a little bit of white but we
went from never doing
coke or anything before smoking bowls
buy a candlelight
in six months
it was it was amazing it was amazing it
was amazing man it was a fun time
we used to ride around and pretend to
look for jobs because he lost his job
he was 18. no he was he always had he
always had a good job he
he just did drugs with me yeah he just
did drugs
it was great and uh we should ride
around and pretend to look for jobs all
day for a whole summer
jesus christ yeah he was it was yours um
we got to get you out of here soon but i
wanna i want you to share the story of
uh
the drive-by oh
okay merced like i tell you
i everyone knows me i'm nice i sell weed
that's thomas not many people named
thomas that are brown yeah no i'm saying
like not a lot
um you mean tomas no no it's thomas
that's my grandpa
[ __ ] it's thomas i'm thomas and
i know a lot of people i know all the
gang i know gangbang i know everybody
man i'm from this town
we all grew up and he's a gangbanger
well he's a [ __ ] goth kid he's a
skater like
we all grew up together and i'm standing
at this place called h w it's a
hamburger stand
i'm just standing waiting for my food
right here's the
it's like the old school from the 50s
diners you know like they'll come out
and bring it to your
window and [ __ ] what time of day it's
two in the afternoon
my girlfriend's at the house i tell
thank god i [ __ ] told her stay home
don't know just chill i'm gonna get the
food real quick i ordered it or no i was
gonna go
sit there and smoke a bowl i waited for
my food like i had it planned out i'm
gonna go get the food
standing there about to order my food
it's a flat window the main
street is five steps behind us you know
one of those
and i'm sure if you're from baltimore
when you hear a whistle you don't know
you don't [ __ ] turn around
you hear someone yell you don't turn
around or the [ __ ] you are you're gonna
shoot
something's gonna happen so there's gang
whistles and i know what [ __ ] gang
whistles from where
i'm from there i hear somebody i see a
car going slow and you don't go slow on
this a main road
i hear a car going slow and i hear
someone whistle
oh nope i'm not [ __ ] turning around
and i hear someone go ah [ __ ] you i
ain't turning around
and then i just feel i hear it and i
feel
i'm remember i am looking at the [ __ ]
lady ordering my food
i'm just ordering my food and i can hear
this going on don't turn around don't
you know better than that and i feel
like someone
popped me in the back of my [ __ ] head
as hard as they could i've never been
hit like that i remember i got hit and
some
like my nose like my snot came out of my
nose a little
damn i felt like you know when you
sneeze hard that's how i felt
and i remember sitting there thinking
somebody punched me in the [ __ ] head
like i got furious i'm super nice but
someone someone now i thought maybe
someone hit me with a bat like it
it hurt and i felt dank but when it
happened
a bunch of [ __ ] hit the front of the
building like a bunch of
like i heard like a bunch of scatters
but i'm not paying attention to that
there's a girl next to me hits the
ground starts holding her leg
oh my god did i just get [ __ ] shot
i hold my head like this and i turn
around but i turn around like oh my god
[ __ ] i'm shot damn it i touch my head
and i just feel like a ball
oh my god i got a [ __ ] shot are you
kidding me but when i turn around i'm
expecting i was still expecting someone
that just cracked me with a [ __ ] bat
and maybe hit that girl i don't see it i
turn around and as i turn around this
[ __ ] like el dorado cadillac
is about 15 feet past there's a 12 13
year old [ __ ] little boy hanging out
the window
same haircut as me hanging out the
[ __ ] window with a little hoodie
like half on hanging out the [ __ ]
window looking at me
pulling in this little shotgun thing
pulling it in
and i remember like oh my [ __ ] god
i'm shy i almost [ __ ] started crying
like oh my god this is it are you
[ __ ] kidding me
i was expecting my blood to start
pumping through my fingers i'm holding
it i go like that and there's a little
bit of blood but not a lot
but there is a ball on the back of my
head right like a [ __ ] fist size ball
and i look at the ground and there's
like train track baby
uh bearings those big metal bearings
yeah [ __ ] full shoved it
pumped it out and tried to shoot me in
the face i have a shotgun i know the the
homemade uh
potato gun yeah we used to have those
yeah the [ __ ] kid but he hit me
directly in the [ __ ] head
damn if he hit me right here i'll be
dead you would be good
but i knew better like don't turn around
who's whistling at you in the [ __ ] nope
everybody knows you bro they'll say
thomas don't [ __ ] turn around
and then my first reaction oddly enough
was
i probably sell your brother's weed
[ __ ] i'm gonna find out who you
are like i'm gonna find out who you are
i guess this street goes all the way
down to the end of my town
i can see these guys stop at a stop
light they don't give a [ __ ] they're
just stopped waiting to go on the
green and i'm sitting there i'm like all
right
okay and i say [ __ ] it i get my car oh
wait at this point the girls on the
ground going oh my [ __ ] god
and i pick one up and it's a steely a
metal steely and i realized like okay
i'm not stizzy i'm gonna get in my car
and chase these [ __ ]
but the ladies serving food the lady
just went like that and got him
she starts looking and i go and that's
why i'm still holding my head and i can
see her looking at the girl
and that's when i started thinking like
[ __ ] dude i just got shot in the head
are you [ __ ] kidding me
but if i got shot for i think i'd be on
the ground right but i thought at first
someone
didn't even knock you down right no no
it made me step forward
but i tried not to like scream because i
wanted whoever the [ __ ] punched me to be
scared when i just
oh damn you know what i mean because i
was i was mad more than i was hurt
but as soon as i realized what happened
i like oh my god i'm shot
[ __ ] and i'm nice as [ __ ] man i'm
[ __ ] nice
i don't want to hurt nobody oh man yeah
i just wanna sell you [ __ ] weed
and i was still selling like a lot of
wheat and my dealer at the time was
he had it in with his northerner fools
they were shooting at each other all the
time
and i was thinking [ __ ] do they think
i'm down with this guy and they tried to
shoot me
chased these guys i co i called the [ __ ]
i don't have a gun i'm like yo
these people are driving around shooting
people in the head you should probably
go get them this is the car
and they the lady in the dispatch got so
mad at me
for not following them through their
house because i got behind him and as
soon as they hit 12th street i go oh
hell no i ain't going falling on 12th
street that's i'm like a shot
it's a bad neighborhood like this is
where you guys are at
i'm gonna let this one go and i
literally turned around like if you
don't follow them
how am i gonna help you like no [ __ ] i
gave you the description the car yeah
because if i fall into the house
what if it's a drug house and some of my
homies are in there with hella hella
weight and guns
i just snitched on all my [ __ ]
friends or people that are gonna come
kill me for showing up at the house with
cops i just let it go i'm sorry i just
wanted to let that one go and as i'm
turning around i remember like
all my pride just breaking like knowing
this little boy tried to
kill me and i did nothing about it it
was the
that's the most embarrassing moment of
my life was not doing anything about it
because i wanted to ram their car they
had two grown men driving like
fat giant mexican dudes tatted 30 40
years old
there's a little boy in the back yeah
shooting [ __ ] people
because that that year like six people
got shot with guns just and
people were driving by at the store bam
just shooting real quick the [ __ ] some
guy got shot in this driveway in the
nice side of town and that's when i
realized like oh
it wasn't meant for me it was for
anybody right you know yeah but thank
god man i almost got [ __ ] shots yeah
for real
and that was the thing i just remember
thinking i'm gonna cut off their older
brother with weed
whoever the [ __ ] it is like i saw him
think like did you ever find out who was
never
no nobody
man dude you gotta you've lived a hell
of a life so far
now i ask everybody that's new when they
come on here
i gave you a heads up before advice to
your 16 year old self and now
looking back and hearing what you and
it's always interesting to me because
jess may paluso said the same thing like
looking
i've never put my [ __ ] together in a
laundry list and looking at it you're
like yeah
damn that's mine yeah so yeah um
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self
i might be different but almost none
because i [ __ ] love the way it turned
out
so the advice will be then my advice
would be like get a contract
work out you fat piece of [ __ ] that's
really it cause i used to be kind of
[ __ ]
in shape when i was younger and started
selling weed and stopped caring
that'd be my only advice like hey stay
in shape you [ __ ] and sign contracts
before you do deals with people that's
the only deal
only thing i there's no other advice man
because
everything led up to me being [ __ ]
stoked you know nothing else all those
packs and
100 miles of drive like driving with
pounds and pounds is [ __ ]
frightening i mean hearing about it gets
me nervous scary man
it's you just going up and down the
freeways and [ __ ] oh yeah just going to
like sack to la la to sac dropping off
packs on the way
it's i mean it's drug dealer [ __ ] it's
it's you make money but in the end man i
got lucky i never got [ __ ] sent to
jail
because i've had friends get almost shot
to death over a pound a week [ __ ] 2
000
are you kidding me so that's my advice
is
almost really that like not much man
because i love everything the way it
turned out i think if i changed it
i'm just lucky i have the coolest job
ever for i really do it's the funnest i
just get paid to
get high and make stuff keep make
content you want to make clothes
do it you know this is for you dude this
is fun yeah this is fun this has been a
lot of fun yeah
um one more time please promote
everything you'd like
um dopaziola.com pushtrees.com that's uh
my clothing website
youtube is dopaziola thank you to
everybody that follows us on there we're
about to hit 900 i'm
very wow that's great so the fans are
unreal man it's i don't have tattoos we
have like 60 tattoos people have blasted
i love all those people that's really
what it is is that's what i want to plug
thank you guys for watching so much
thank you for supporting everything and
letting me
be able to get up and get as high as i
can go
well work was [ __ ] awesome today you
know
yeah yeah thank you so much you got it
brother thank you appreciate you being
here appreciate it
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com make sure you
subscribe to the youtube
talk to you all next week
[Music]
you
[Music]